le chef du parti québécois pour le st
pierre plamondon a dansé par voie de
l'être aujourd'hui qui ne le sera pas
candidat à l'élection partielle de marie
victorin qu'il veut mettre toute son
attention sur la préparation des
élections générales un qui s'en viennent
on est dans un électorale et cette
circonscription mais les vacances on
doit tenir une élection partielle
pourquoi ne plonge pas dans cette
bataille électorale intérimaire pense à
pierre demandeur bonsoir bonsoir 24,60
merci plusieurs ont dit plusieurs
observateurs disent que vous avez pris
la bonne décision tu sais pas le temps
dans le fond de l'est vous brûler dans
marie victorin
on est à moins d'un an des élections
générales j'ai la responsabilité comme
chef du parti québécois de préparer les
troupes préparer la plate forme et dans
la mesure où le gouvernement le goût ne
voulait pas déclencher immédiatement
étiez toujours secrète la date de
déclenchement le départ ciel on
regardait vers une élection partielle
qui aurait pu durer plusieurs mois à une
date indéterminée donc
parce qu'il faut préparer le terrain
préparer l'élection générale mais
également parce qu'on a une excellente
candidature avec une assise un ancrage
local et ça c'est important de le
mentionner
je pense qu'en effet si la bonne
décision à prendre je le dis le moi je
n'ai jamais résidé à longueuil je
n'avais pas de lien et j'ai choisi ma
circonscription que j'annoncerai
ultérieurement et qui
serait bousquet pardon il paraît que ce
serait peut-être rimouski
on va essayer chacune d'entre elles je
ferai une annonce ultérieurement mais on
avait évidemment réfléchi à tous au
parti québécois et on voit tout
simplement suivre notre plan de
préparation pour des élections qui sont
très importantes et il pend et semble
que monsieur nantel qui a été député
dans ce coin et là pendant quelques
années fédéral pour le problème [ __ ] pour
être candidat il ya beaucoup de rumeurs
qui circulent c'est de bonne guerre et
on va faire des annonces dans les
prochains jours donc on fera pas languir
non plus éternellement mais il ya un
ordre dans tout ce puis on voit suscite
ce sera votre choix le candidat où il y
aura une
réunion d'investiture il ya toujours une
investiture au parti québécois il ya
toujours la liberté de se présenter les
sas est une particularité de notre parti
qui est entièrement démocratique mais
c'est sûr que ont identifié un certain
nombre de candidatures qui ont levé la
main pour cette partielle là et il ya
des candidatures intéressantes qui qui
vont être préservés est un piège pour
vous au fond d'y aller comme chef parce
que perdre une élection même si fait une
élection partielle remettez en cause du
leadership et ultime en l'avenir du
véhicule non
une question davantage de se poser la
question où le temps du chef du parti
québécois est bien investi est-ce que ça
être sur le terrain c'était ma première
d'ailleurs en parlant dans des cégeps et
des universités comme aujourd'hui
j'étais à chaque outil en étant avec des
chambres de commerce des syndicats des
intervenants ou est ce que c'est de se
concentrer sur un seul côté sur 125 puis
pour autant on a on aime marie victorin
parce que c'est un comté où on retrouve
énormément d'indépendantistes mais dans
la mesure où on a une bonne candidature
une candidature intéressante à mettre de
l'avant évidemment que tout se devait
être mis dans la balance et il faut
rappeler qu'il y aura donc deux
rendez-vous dans marie victorin et le
rendez vous décisif ce sera les
élections générales et c'est là dessus
qu'on est concentré au parti québécois
doit vous dites que dans mes lectures 1
et beaucoup des indépendantistes ya
peut-être encore beaucoup
d'indépendantistes au québec 20 30%
c'est pas vrai il reste que ces gens là
sont désillusionnés par ce n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour donc il y en a beaucoup
qui sont rangés et ranger du côté de la
claque dans les cabinets ministériels
les coûts de gens sont à la cac et sont
satisfaits de discours nationaliste
alors comment on prépare une plateforme
électorale comment on bat ici on se
prépare
d'affronter une élection quand on sait
que la plupart de ses troupes ont été
attirés par notre parti premièrement
cette démontrer qu'on attire des gens de
qualité puis qu'on aura des troupes
fraîches et forte pour les prochaines
élections ensuite c'est d'être unique
dans ce qu'on propose on est unique en
langue française on est seul parti à
dire que le projet de loi de la iv ne va
pas assez loin notamment propose la loi
101 dans les cégeps unique parce qu'on
propose indépendance du québec alors que
la caq accumule les échecs dans toutes
ses demandes refusées auprès du fédéral
et des vraies demandes importantes comme
par exemple 6 milliards de dollars en
santé qui ne nous sommes pas transférer
ou par exemple l'application de la loi
101 aux entreprises comme air canada
donc en environnement sur certaines
questions sociales qui nous tiennent à
coeur comme les cpe comme le fait qu'il
ya toujours une crise du logement puis
que le gouvernement ne fait pas grand
chose il ya plusieurs sujets sur lequel
sur lesquels le parti québécois auront
une proposition qui existent active est
nécessaire pour un avenir meilleur au
québec comme dans le défi que vous avez
est aussi celui des deux autres partis
d'opposition du québec solidaire qui
mise beaucoup sur cette circonscription
à mes risques et libéraux aussi sont
très faibles comme vous allez dans les
sondages
donc est ce que vous craignez de
présider
ce parti au moment de son
la dernière respiration de son déclin et
il est impératif qu'on me sers souvent
mais moi je me trouve privilégié de dire
la vérité sur une question aussi
fondamentale que le fait que le québec
devrait être un pays et j'ai hâte aux
prochaines élections parce qu'on va
amener des forces fraîches vive puis on
va être très authentique on va donner
l'heure juste aux québécois sur pleins
dangereux qu'ils sont vrais et d'ici là
les sondages on est temps de bouger moi
j'ai commencé ma schéma course à la
chefferie à 5% pour les gens me
mentionnait même paul et les sondages
c'est pas la raison pour laquelle on
fait de la politique on leur en fait de
la politique par conviction on aura de
belles convictions à préparer la propose
aux québécois aux prochaines élections
puisque parler de sondages vont les
derniers sondages montrent que votre
niveau de notoriété et pas très élevé
c'est un fait mais les sondages
concernant la caq eux sont très élevé et
persistant depuis le début de cette
pandémie là malgré que trois partis
d'opposition qui frappe fort sur le
gouvernement pour croire que c'est pas
facile dans l'opposition actuellement de
démolir
le gouvernement là parce qu'il reste
populaire dans l'esprit des québécois
ouais mais les élections c'est le moment
justement où on fait le bilan on évalue
les choix donc tout important de se
préparer en fonction de cet objectif là
et les choses sont appelés à changer
comme je vous dis on peut pas simplement
faire de la politique en fonction des
sondages parce que la seule certitude au
niveau des sondages c'est qu'ils sont
appelés à bouger donc mieux vaut faire
de la politique pour des raisons plus
profondes par conviction et attirer des
gens de conviction et ce je pense qu'on
va démontrer ce au cours des prochaines
semaines des prochains mois qu'on attire
des gens intéressants autour de
conviction qu'ils sont vrais qui sont
également nécessaires pour un avenir du
québec
meilleure que ce que nous réserve notre
place dans le canada le décline un
guichetier culturelles notamment
convient alors le sujet pierre plamondon
merci vous est rendu disponible ce soir
et puis bien sûr on suit de très près
c'est son courage bonsoir et merci pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]